hey everybody guess what what nothing
nothing hey everybody guess what what
doing it my way
hey everybody guess what
what ching chong ching chong guess what
what 100 episodes and I am so excited to
be here I think I'm lying I think I
think there's a lot of pressure on me
right now
why and I feel just overwhelmed with all
the stress because you know I feel like
people think that the hundred episode
was supposed Pepa so supposed to be like
magical or something but it's not going
to be oh it's just gonna be what it is
okay and I want to say this to you all
of you in the room and outside of the
world may peace enter your heart may joy
and serenity seep inside your eyes so
that you may see the light and I
appreciate all of you listeners may God
be with you and I've been reflecting a
lot about us as a group as a family as
an army and I'm the captain mm-hmm I
just want to throw that out there yeah
and slap King and urban Bobby all that
stuff but you know we all met in
different times and there's an origin to
this podcast there's a mythology to it
and I'd like to talk about how we all
met and how this podcast got started and
I know a lot of people that be listening
to us over the last year you kind of
know but [ __ ] it we're doing it anyway
and I would like to start off with the
way I met George you were George before
me huh I did yeah I even known George
longer then what happened was on when
they were starting maker studios I think
I came in and they wanted to sign me up
to do videos and stuff and I came in and
they said what about this Jerrica all
these people has producers and I could
see one guy raised his hand and go I
want to do
but he had this Timothy McVeigh vibe he
look like he had a u-haul and he was
like making bombs he looked like he had
a u-haul yeah honestly when asked about
your George I was like that everywhere
anyone but him like I'll take in the
gardener I do not want him just based on
here and I said is it based on energy
appearance skin color all of it I'm like
I can't do it and then like a couple of
months you do some videos and people
leave Terrica just doing this Mickey is
gone although these people leave right
and then through just the years George
was left person persist experiences yeah
that's true and the reason why I like
him now is because you can tell that he
is into it and he has changed our lives
for the better he is helping my brother
out immensely and I hated you but I
think there's a little love there now so
I met George and then I met kalila off
of tinder and let's be real that's not
like hi open it's right what can I paint
you the scenario of how I swipe less how
I swiped left Wow right I was actually
in bed with a boy named Cal I remember
him really yeah I met him oh yeah so I
was having you know I at this point my
life always wondered because like Bobby
lives up here and you were living down
in Long Beach so I was like either her
range was set to really far yeah or she
was near here some no no she was like 27
so he lied about his age heath because I
was only searching up until 40 so I was
going I think my range was like 32 to 40
that's what I'm doing wrong that's
exactly what you're doing get the lie on
the [ __ ] 322 yeah so he lied and said
he was 37 yeah nice he let the dog in
and
at this point in my life I had just you
know been having like casual like
hookups with the eye so I've been seeing
this guy for like a meathead not the
meathead
but he's thick like a thick of bulky
body bill 20 to think think bein with no
mask oh okay big thicker white dude yeah
and he was young 22 years old yeah yeah
yeah and there's a little acne in it
squeaky voice we could come like that
and he got older whoa
yeah and I think that we had just
finished hooking up through tinder yeah
I really didn't care about him that much
and I think that I was very clear with
him that I wanted nothing more than just
you know a physical relationship and so
I saw Bobby's name and I even turned it
I was probably naked and I put my eye
I showed him my phone I was like oh my
god look who it is I'm gonna swipe left
I swipe right I mean is that good right
good I think that we were gonna match of
course I didn't think that you would
swipe right that's where I was yeah and
there's no way about no because I know
how give it a I've seen man tinder they
just swipe right at everything they
don't discriminate I think women are a
little bit more oh yeah dude um and so
dick is so dead he's gotta be complex
[ __ ] for me there and so that's how it
was I showed it to him and then we
matched and I was like oh my god Cal
look why matched with and he was a wow
that's crazy and [ __ ] yeah that was the
beginning of it and then I remember
meeting Cal at Europe one of your
birthday parties and what karaoke now
yeah so I saw him and I could tell that
he was like with her mind up with me I
know but he was there and you know they
had sex with him right date yeah but I
knew oh I knew that there was something
there he was cute right you'd really
kill yeah and I'm just like I don't want
to compete with the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and then she broke up with me on
Facebook once ah how do you ever skip to
that I go from there to there yeah she
broke up with in this when two months
and within a month of dating him I don't
want to get into it because personal no
it's not but within a month of dating
him I had some like weird symptoms and I
went to go get a CT scan and they found
a mass in my lungs there was a huge mass
in my lungs and in my head I was like I
remember when the doctor told me the
news she was like hey it doesn't look
good this is what's going on and in my
head I was like oh my god I have lung
cancer and I'm only 27 years old I was
like how did this happen but then so I
had just started seeing him three weeks
into it like I don't want to get into a
relationship with anyone like I want to
focus on like feeling better I just
assumed it was something bad so I loved
her Facebook I was like hey so yeah I
don't want to see you anymore yeah it
was crazy yeah and I rarely check my
facebook oh and then he was like were
you crazy I don't care if you're not
like if you're sick or whatever turned
out to be benign thank God that's how
yeah and then can we move on but beyond
you and me know we're still at you and
me yeah and then what happened after
that was then you when did we commit
though January no no we committed
already verbally but we here's how I
know though that I think oh you're a
piece of [ __ ] this makes me was.how I
know I go this is the right one because
I did the worst thing you could possibly
do and she still stayed with me I
announced I announced her abortion on
David chose podcast oh yeah while she
was at the abortion clinic that's your
litmus for knowing this yeah and when
she didn't break up with me I'm like
she's the one she she stayed in it
because that's a lot of [ __ ] you
have to deal with oh god the internet
yeah I told my brother I'd go do it
relationships I was like what how much
[ __ ] the other one can take and she
has a threshold for [ __ ] like a deep
chasm here yeah it's huge because of the
kind of [ __ ] that I do is like
unbearable you go deep I go so deep and
she's just like I'm gonna have to let it
go this is what it is
right so that's how I know and then how
do you meet Gilbert kalila well that's
not before we even met you you guys
already did something together right so
in a podcast without my permission he
goes on David chose podcast and he says
yeah my girlfriend now needs two dicks
to come so he tells a story about how I
remember that
how previously I was really creepy the
way face got red and happy I remember
that roast by the way guys we have
Dorothy at our greatest tiger belly fat
here joining us today she was handpicked
and picked so yes he goes into
podcasting is like my girlfriend needs
two dicks to come I remember that oh
yeah and that's kind of where the whole
world of podcast where the seed was
planted in my head because I Bobbi's
like you know what why don't you come on
the show and tell your story and sort of
defend yourself
I went on the ton David shows podcast
didn't defend myself I ended up oh you
did expanding on the story and [ __ ]
myself over but and I got so much like
Internet vitriol from that like this
girl's a sociopath she knew you know she
needs she's basically let because I had
a polyamorous relationship before I was
the [ __ ] spawn of Satan basically
right yeah and her tinder profile said
wonderla I didn't say I would never put
you that's a basic [ __ ] you put white
girl wondering yes you did ask you
what's wonder lust I did not that's not
what I anyway yeah it did but let's move
on to active it's a fact but move on
wonder loss USA
was I a bossy [ __ ] like yeah yeah you
see wonder lust Jesus so we went on the
podcast and that's when the idea of even
I never even understood like the world
of podcasting uh-huh and then I and we
did that I was like oh maybe we can down
the road this is something that I would
be interested in in not doing for myself
but even like producing or being a part
of so then she one day said I want to do
one I didn't want to do one because I
was gonna do him with fat black Erik
Griffin Erik Griffin that black Erik and
I went to all things comedy even had a
meeting there was Sun you guys up right
now and then he had went on the road I
did and that we just never did it we
just you know you just you live your
life and just never did it and then
she's like I want to do one and I want
her to do one she wanted to an all-girls
one I think that was eventually the plan
maybe her awesome some other people so
we went to I remember going to the
Guitar Center to get some of the stuff
remember I know we had a smaller mic for
myself yeah we went yeah I would attach
a mic to the computer yeah on Garageband
cloudy and there were no tables and I
would just record and I recorded 10
episodes some with myself and some with
bobbi and after the 10th 11th episode we
you know we thought like well no we
thought let's just do it for real forget
it and then I met you Gilbert during a
fight we had a fight mm-hmm Jenna Jenna
invited you back yeah yeah Jenna invited
you without my permission yeah yeah I'm
like who the [ __ ] is this butterfly of a
[ __ ] Filipino bastard and you came
flying into the room Thank You massive
[ __ ] owned the place
also I know what I wore now I know why
you say that ya think I was so gay I
wore this show gay the tightest pants
yeah I'm like wow [ __ ] wanderlust gay
dude
yeah wonder less I mean dude I swear to
God I thought that you were a full-blown
[ __ ] juggler you know I know basically
based on my extra small hmm sure yeah
yeah it was crazy and I got nice and
there's like he's a comedian or he's a
sketch guy and then when we did this and
you said that we needed an engineer or
somebody to help us you volunteered
right no he asked me a Priscilla's
coffee well we had tried recording just
you and I and it the the computer
crashed everything went to [ __ ] and the
whole hour had been lost so I was
thinking to myself you know who can do
this and then Jonah was like hey
Gilbert's really good with computers
that's all she said
liar yeah but she's also shitty with
computers so me being good at computers
like helping her with email yeah right
so I was like hey do you want to just
sit in as a third person and just watch
the program run and make sure it's
running while we talk yeah that's all
was this hit stop yeah hit start and
then hit why do you want to do that well
she asked me just like people why did
you want to do what though honestly yeah
I get to meet Bob you late what that
feels good that's though I didn't even
know she was dating you either now and
then generally oh yeah she's dating like
this kook first of all Jenna didn't know
who you are
idiot she's like she said yeah Jenna
does who I am no at that time yeah I'll
show you why she went like because when
I first met her was at the Comedy Store
years ago and when I first met her I
thought she was cute yeah and she opened
her mouth yeah she was wondering wonder
was did yeah and so I'm like no so she
knew I was because I'm friends with
esther povitsky yeah yeah send their
friends so then but then when you did
that podcast I think I thought wow this
guy's funny he kind of knows what he's
doing and I think it didn't take that
long for me to go he just should be a
part of it yeah and when I had met him
we met at a coffee shop for the first
time even before you met Gilbert Sweeney
and I remember I was wearing pajama
pants and like looking like pretty
disastrous
water lost
and he he basically roasted me at a
coffee shop he's like who the hell are
you what are you wearing I was like
really well just making fun I mean kind
of all Jenna's friends they're all like
hippies you look homeless I decide you
love it and so I was like hey I kind of
really like this guy is kind of like a
[ __ ] kind of dude my kind of how did
McVeigh get involved all his cousin left
left a comment on one of them I'd
emailed Bobby and he didn't respond so
that's never yeah you should know that
no I know I know p-- so Bryce Bryce left
a couple I still intact George George
why are you working on this on one of
our tiger Billy Instagram photos hmm and
then I replied with yeah George why
aren't you because I had met George once
at maker and I knew that you know you
well I you know I I responded uh if
they're ever having a hunger games for
who can be Gilbert's assistant I'm in
clever enough is this right enough with
us will this get their attention you
were willing to be I remember that Oh
God the foot in the door and Gilbert
learned on the job how to yeah cuz that
other guy you guys I'm not gonna say his
name the other guy you guys had before
we had another guy oh yeah I had to
learn everything from him which is all
right he was the guy wrong something
happened I know what happens it's often
have a lot of things happen I came in
that's how it all happened
that guy's completely out of her life I
don't even know he's a great guy I'm
talking I'm like two two years I forgot
about him yeah that's right Alex you
taught me and I think what you're not
taking that out know what I'm just
nothing no you're not marking in indeed
it's not marking Bobby got it maybe he's
a very well you know what I'm gonna see
his name 20 more times it's Bob yeah
he's just a he was very expensive and I
know at that time we could
afford him and his skills my skills were
sorry birds were free and even though
they weren't probably very good at the
time we were like [ __ ] it let's let's
roll with Gilbert yeah you too baby
[Music]